so what do you study afore you want to  be a nurse or something why do you say  that because you're so concerned about  my personal idea yeah but if I was a guy  you would just automatically assume but  I was gonna be a doctor right  yeah I'm basically just your average  sexist grease monkey oh speaking of it's  my brother if it wants me to be the  doctor he doesn't quite understand that  I got into college first get straight  A's and then apply to medical school no  sir  Mia come on already get on it well at  least he believes in you yeah yeah three  maybe two decades and lasts for seven  what he could get mean so much too maybe  he wants me to put him back together for  free when he crashes